celui qui responsable du dossier prenez
lice legault a nommé responsable du
dossier il est avec nous en direct
gilles bélanger député dafunk adjoint
parlementaire donc du 1er mai sur le
volet internet bonsoir monsieur bélanger
bonsoir serein j'ai un tableau que je
vous montrais verrez une confirmé c'est
vraiment les vrais chefs ou cd veut
manger à envier à janvier 2021 avait 250
mille foyers qui restait à brancher
haute vitesse il en resterait
aujourd'hui 70 mais le score c'est une
vision team et 70000 où c'est vraiment
ça
c'est vraiment sûr d'un fond il y en
avait en
et aujourd'hui je vous dirai à peu près
70 milles qui reste à trancher si le
transept un bon et d'ici le 30 septembre
qu'est ce qui va arriver combien vous
allez embranchée aka méthodes
traditionnelles le glacier brand
c'est à dire la méthode traditionnelle
en bois si on peut par fibre et tout le
monde la fibre optique ça coûte 20 à 30
me de l'ordre qui n'auraient donc des
milliers de foyers qui vont être branché
par le sans fil est la meilleure
solution que nous avons trouvée
qui offre des vitesses les débits
vraiment intéressant donc tout québec je
dirais qu'on a déjà une couverture à
100% date d'aujourd'hui mais maintenant
il ya des contrats qui ont été établies
pour la fibre optique et si ces
contrôleurs ont un retard de livraison
le sans fil vont être fournis que ce
soit en attendant ou de façon permanente
pour s'assurer que vraiment une promesse
d'offrir 100 % internet à tout le québec
elle est réalisée au plus tard deux
temps ok mais des soixante dix mille
foyers qui attendent qu'ils veulent
avoir la haute vitesse vous dites que
tous d'ici la fin septembre
s'ils n'ont pas vu camions de fibres
s'activer vont pouvoir s'abonner à
stirling de la masse les satellites les
3000 satellite qui font tourner la terre
et vous allez payer une partie de
l'installation pas mal installations que
vous allez payer 40 dollars par mois ce
que c est à peu près ça tout le
territoire compétitif ou aux fils heures
parce qu'on a des équipes sur le terrain
qui évalue les fournisseurs vont voir un
retard ou pas et déjà on ne bascule
istomin de région avec une offre sans
fil et lorsque le fut l'heure parce que
moi je préconise que la fibre optique
est la meilleure technologie à long
terme silas disponibles le citoyen par
un choix soit qu'ils gardent stirling
space x ou qui désirent
s'abonner au final fibre optique ce à
peu près 140 par mois le stirling pour
avoir accès internet haute vitesse où
j'allais défrayer combien de ceux 140 $
pour les gens
l'équipement est gratuit c'est vivre et
à la maison ont des frais 40 dollars par
mois ci après six semaines le client ce
film est disponible ils vont pouvoir
cesser le service le citoyen n'est pas
commis a dû longtemps mais j'peux vous
et moi je suis j'ai passé le mois de
juillet à faire le tour du québec
cheveux blancs sablons labrador j'ai
testé dans cinquante six endroits
différents et c'est fantastique au
niveau de la solution story ça va être
des solutions qui vous a aidé au niveau
de la mobilité comme on fait très
concrètement le lin laurentides moi je
connais plein de gens qui attendent
depuis la fibre optique soit de même
atteint qui est belle ou d'autres nous
disent vas pas avant six mois on sait
pas trop comme j'avais dit au début trop
cher pour les compagnies même avec
l'argent de leurs données bref comment
ils font concrètement pourra recevoir la
coupole de sterling
mais avant jc rick avait maintes fois
une promesse
et on est à présent chez tout le monde
pour les copains carte interactive qui
existe chaque citoyen à la sim cartes
interactives au québec ça va nous dire
qu'ils votent branchies et k61 embêtant
l'eydap les dates sont inscrites au
niveau de la carte il ya un scénario et
une action qui leur est à faire pour
s'assurer qu'ils ont internet haute
vitesse au plus tard le 30 septembre
c'est dans un mois sera donc on voit sur
le site comment s'appelle le oui ton
lors le québec coincé à baroville carte
internet haute vitesse on regarde si
elle du retard ou pas dans région et
sinon 30 septembre on s'abonne au
satellite qu'on a vu d'ailleurs ce qu'on
ne la photo avant de quitter vendredi
les gens par sa gamme des ovnis dans le
ciel du québec c'était le la sma de 30
satellites supplémentaires des lamas ce
qu'on voit sur la photo ça c'est le
reflet du soleil sur les panneaux
solaires des satellites
c'est très juste très intrigant vendredi
dans la nuit mais c'était ça les fameux
sa télé se mélanger oui nous avons
manqué toute la carte du début il
n'existait pas de carte au québec c'est
québec il a menti 2 à 0 très bien merci
beaucoup monsieur bélanger à la
prochaine au revoir